Land und
[Musik]
Precht schönen guten Morgen Richard
hallo Markus wo erreiche ich dich in
südtir wonst Ernst im schönen Botzen du
bist du bist in brzen in meiner Heimat
ich bin in brutzen und habe in kurzester
Zeit ganz viel über südm Vortrag
gehalten und ganz viel über südtol
gelernt erzähl wichtigste Erkenntnis wie
wie groß Südtirol ist und Südtirol hat
ungefähr so viel Einwohner wie Hannover
aber weltpolitisch eine vielbedeutendere
Rolle gespielt den hover Vergleich und
hier war gerade Landtagswahl ist richtig
und und diese Landtagswahl wegt den Sinn
für das nachdenken weil es sind 16
Parteien angetreten und 13 werden dem
Land Tag angehört und das erinnert mich
ja so ein bisschen auch an deutsche
Verhältnisse ich frage mich nämlich hier
so gerade aus meinem Südtiroler Exil ob
Deutschland sich allmählich politisch
Genen südtirrol orientiert Sarah
Wagenknecht ja dein Bündnis aufgestellt
da wird eine Partei draus und ich
erinnere mich ja noch als alter Mann ne
an die Welt in als es in Deutschland nur
drei Parteien gab und jetzt kommt
mittlerweile alle 10 15 Jahre eine neue
dazu damals waren das ja nur CDU SPD und
fd
und die Welt war so einfach ne die SPD
war links die CDU war rechts FDP eierte
so dazwischen war mit dem einen Mal mit
dem anderen und dann erinnere ich mich
daran wie die Grünen gegründet wurde und
ich weiß auch was da los war in den
Anfang der 80er ne ja also 7980
gegründet ne und dann also ich fand die
da ganz toll ne das war für mich so für
mich voll die Alternative weil ich kam
ja auch aus der Umwelt und
Naturschutzbewegung war natürlich genau
das worauf ich gewartet hatte
und ich weiß aber dass meine Lehrer
entsetzt waren also die für die waren
die Grünen der Untergang des Abendlandes
also das waren kryptokommunisten dar
daran hat sich ja nicht viel geändert ja
wenn man heute mal reinschaut in die
eine oder andere Kommentierung aber d
also überlegst ne also Franz Josef
Straus wollte die grünenwgen als
verfassungswidrige Partei verbieten
lassenm autograf Lamsdorf der damalige
Wirtschaftsminister meinte er weigere
sich FDP FDP renlos zuzusehen wie aus
Deutschland eine Republik von Marx und
Morgentau wird Morgentau ist jener
berühmte usamerikanische Politiker der
den Vorschlag gemacht hatte Deutschland
nach 1945 zu deindustrialisieren und in
einen Agrarstaat zu verwandeln genau
also so heftig fielen damals die
Reaktionen aus und ich weiß auch unter
Lehrern und so weiter dachte das
Abendland geht unter wenn die Grünen je
irgendwo in ein Parlament reingehen
würden und heute muss man sagen sind
eine staatstragende Partei ja das das
ist ist interessant ne also die die
Grünen damals ich habe noch diese Bilder
im Kopf diese diese Männer mit diesen
langen berärten und diesen sehr langen
Haaren also Friseurbesuche waren da
nicht so das Thema die dann strickend
auf Parteitagen rumsen wpolis in Gen
zuvor selbstgestrickten wolfpolis genau
oder die Blumentöpfe auf ihre
Abgeordneten Bänke stellten als sie ins
Parlament einzogen ja damit ein bisschen
Grün reinkommt richtig und heute muss
man so wie du sagst ne also die die an
den Grünen kann man sich ja bis heute da
ist ja ein ein ein Kulturkampf im Grunde
zurückgekommen von dem ich dachte den
würden wir so nicht wiedershen also ich
ich habe das in der Form so nicht kommen
sehen ja und das obwohl alle grüne
inzwischen Anzucht tragen und bis auf
Anton Hofreiter keiner mehr lange Haare
hat also der hat ja noch die Maskottchen
Frisur von früher aber alle anderen
haben sich davon ja völlig verabschiedet
ja absolut aber es ist interessant ich
mich ich finde einfach spannend daran
wie gehen wir mit neugegründeten
Parteien um ja ich wollte noch einen
einen Satz zu den Grünen sagen Richard
das ist ja schon interessant also das
das das hat ja der deutschen der der
politischen Kultur in Deutschland ja
durchaus gut getan ja die anderen
Parteien waren gezwungen endlich auf das
Umweltthema zu reagierenagieren genau
man vergisst in dem Zusammenhang auch
sehr interessant die erste Partei ne die
ein ein ein grünes ein ein
Umweltprogramm hatte sozusagen war die
FDP sie haben es dann nun nie konsequent
zu Ende verfolgt oder die hat auf die
Grünen reagiert indem man Walter
Wallmann ja
den glaube ehemaligen Frankfurter
Oberbürgermeister der wurde dann
Umweltminister und der galt so als das
krasseste Gegenteil als ein Mann der mit
diesem Thema nichts zu tun hat das war
jedenfalls das Image das man hatte und
man hat gesagt das ist doch sozusagen
wie kann man sowas machen ne aber es war
auf jeden Fall zu sehen die CDU musste
reagieren alle Parteien mussten jetzt
irgendwie zeigen dann kamen solche
Initiativen wie bleifreies Benzin das
ist dann unter der CDU reggierung
vorangetrieben worden man muss
zumindestens zeigen dass einem das Thema
nicht gleichgültig ist um die Grünen
nicht so stark werden zu lassen
Katalysator und alles was dann soat ble
Benzin das waren so die die ersten
grünen die ersten Aktionen die man
gemacht hat um grüne Themen in die
Politik zu implementieren ja und heute
gibt's jausagen also ganz klare
Frontenbildung und wenn dann jemand wie
Friedrich Merz z.B sagt unser
Hauptgegner sind die Grünen und und
dabei einfach unter Tisch fallen lässt
in wie vielen Landes Parlamenten die
Grünen ja mit in der Regierung sind
teils natürlich auch mit der CDU dann
merkst du die ganze Widersprüchlichkeit
ja das wirlich zunehmen also das ist
funktioniert nicht also wenn man sagt
unser Hauptgegner ist die Grünen dann
spekuliert wahrscheinlich Friedrich Merz
da drauf dass Leute die lieber AFD jetzt
wählen wollen als CDU wieder
zurückkommen weil natürlich für die AFD
Wähler sind die Grünen der Hauptgegner
ne und wenn die CDU das übernimmt hofft
sie ein Teil ihrer Klientel
zurückzubekommen so und was ich nur der
Gedanke den ich gerade noch äußern
wollte also natürlich kann man den
Grünen viele viele Vorwürfe machen und
vor allen Dingen dieses das das merke
ich auch immer das ist wirklich
interessant und das bestätigen auch
Kollegen und das meine ich jetzt gar
nicht in irgendeiner Form böse oder so
man merkt bei den Grünen da sind viele
Leute die kommen aus den aus den Unis
und so weiter die kommen aus dem
akademischen Betrieb und die haben das
sozusagen die versuchen ihren ihren Job
so gut wie möglich so penibel wie
möglich zu machen manchmal ist der
Übergang zwischen penibel und pedantisch
ist dann sehr sehr sehr sehr schmal der
der Grad ja man versucht alles zu
kontrollieren man versucht genau
abzustecken im Vorfeld was was werden
wir jetzt besprechen äh ist es gut für
dich dort aufzutreten oder eher nicht
also möglichst kein Risiko gehen äh das
sieht man dann auch ja an an an an den
Leuten die dann kommen oder eben auch
nicht kommen man versucht möglichst viel
zu kontrollieren und das und das letzte
Mal wo du das wirklich sehen konntest
diesen Versuch wirklich topdown von oben
nach unten richtig reinzieren und zu
kontrollieren und deswegen auch dieses
dieses Image glaube ich dieser dieser
Verbots verbotspartei die sie ja de
facto eigentlich gar nicht sind aber
dieses Image kommt genau daher ne
reinreieren von oben aus dem
Wirtschaftsministerium ganz runter bis
in den letzten Heizungskeller rein und
den Leuten genau vorzuschreiben was
jetzt in welchen Etappen zu passieren
hat genau und das ist das ist sozusagen
man man man traut da den Leuten ein
bisschen ein bisschen weniger zu äh und
und und sagt dann das müssen wir euch
jetzt schon schon sagen wie das zu
laufen hat oder auch nicht ich glaube
trotzdem und deswegen ich ich haer da
manchmal auch und denke es kann doch
nicht euer Ernst sein der Welt jetzt
sozusagen weiß machen zu wollen dass am
deutschen Klimaschutz am deutschen
Klimaschutz sich der Klimaschutz der
ganzen Welt
entscheidet gesprochen also diese
Vorstellung wir werden Klima
weleltmeister und umweltweltmeister und
dann nimmt sich die Welt ein Beispiel
daran so wird das mit sehr hoher
Wahrscheinlichkeit nicht funktionieren
der der Punkt ist aber und darüber denke
ich manchmal nach
es ist natürlich schon so wenn die
größte ökologische Bewegung in Europa
und das sind die Deutschen grünen wenn
die scheitern mit ihrem ökologischen
Projekt dann ist das natürlich mit Blick
auf ganz Europa kein gutes Signal ja
also wenn wenn die größte ökologische
Bewegung in
Europa baden geht mit dieser Vision dann
wird's für alle anderen auch wahnsinnig
schwer und deswegen denke ich manchmal
es hat schon ein gewisse Berechtigung
das Thema so so vehement vorzutragen
aber die Gefahr dass man die Leute dann
irgendwann dabei verliert und die das
Gefühl haben es geht nur noch um Klima
und die Themen die mich bewegen
interessieren keinen mehr und
interessieren vor allen Dingen euch in
Berlin nicht mehr das ist die große
Gefahr und auf dem auf dem Ticket sind
einige mittlerweile unterwegs da hast du
Hubert eiwanger der genau genau diesen
Trigger nutzt und du hast jemanden wie
Sarah Wagenknecht der genau diesen
Trigger nutzt und damit sind wir genau
beim Thema mm ich finde noch interessant
die die anderen neuparteien zu sehen
also die Grünen waren ja die erste neup
Partei in der Bundesrepublik dann kam
die PDS die sich dann irgendwann mit der
WASG zusammen zur Linkspartei formiert
hat und da war natürlich das gleiche da
der hat man dann grundsätzlich
vorgeworfen die besteht eigentlich nur
aus alten sedkadern das dürfte am Anfang
nicht unberechtigt gewesen sein aber die
Partei hat dieser sdkader ja relativ
schnell verloren aber auch hier gab es
den Versuch einfach zu sagen die gehören
jetzt so ag nicht mit an den Tisch ne
also die die mit Kommunisten oder
Exkommunisten oder mit Leuten die in die
DDR verstrickt waren auch in Verbrechen
und so weiter mit denen wollen wir
nichts zu tun haben also so genau wie
bei den Grünen die Haltung war mit denen
wollen wir überhaupt nichts zu tun haben
die stürzen das Abendland in den
Untergang das den gleichen Umgang gab es
und auch über ganz lange Zeit hin weg
mit der Linkspartei bis dann einige in
der Linkspartei salonfähig wurden wie
Sarah Wagenknecht oder Gregor Gesi den
eigentlich jeder mag oder Bodo ramelo
der erfolgreicher Ministerpräsident ist
als die AFD gegründet wurde hatte ich
erstmal das Gefühl das wir nicht ernst
genommen weil Lucke niemand war den
jemand ernstnah der wirkte auch nicht
bedrohlich irgendwie in seiner Art so
ein bisschen pedantisch bisschen verquer
und so aber als die Partei dann den
starkeren Rechtskurs eingeschlagen hatte
dann war es das gleiche und das gilt ja
bis heute dass man sagt mit den können
wir uns nicht an einen Tisch setzen also
Parteien verändern sich aber interessant
ist immer wenn eine neue Partei
gegründet wird dann sind alle anderen
Parteien natürlich erstmal tot dagegen
und befürchten dass es irgendwie den
großen Untergang gibt und das ist im
Augenblick ja auch die Rezeption der
wagenknechtpartei ich habe irgendwo
gelesen die Partei sei tiefrot und
tiefrot ist für mich die deutsche
Wirtschaft komplett zu verstaatlichen
und das Eigentum abzuschaffen das wäre
für mich tiefrot sowas sehe ich da
nichtm lass uns gleich mal ein bisschen
da einsteigen das ist sehr interessant
die die diese noch ist es ja nur ein
Verein ne der da gegründet worden ist
das ist auch sehr interessant
also ja ein ein Bündnis und ein eV ein
eingetragener Verein und die
Parteigründung folgt dann wahrscheinlich
erst im Januar 24 aber will noch ein
einen Satz zur AFD sagen bei der AFD und
und da merkt man auch diese Unsicherheit
auf allen Ebenen die AFD ist keine
Partei wie alle anderen auch die AFD ist
eine Partei die einem tatsächlich Sorge
bereiten muss wenn man sich die Leute
anguckt die darin das Sagen haben äh und
es gibt ja so dieses Argument zu sagen
lass die erstmal in der
Regierungsverantwortung kommen und dann
werden die sich schon entzaubern und
dann wird sich zeigen die haben
überhaupt keine Rezepte und die haben
eigentlich gar keine wirkliche Idee also
man muss ja auch ein Unterschied machen
und das ist ja gerade jetzt bei der
Gründung der wagenknechtpartei wichtig
zwischen den führenden Leuten in einer
Partei und deren Ausrichtung und was sie
mutmaßlich tun würden wenn sie an der
Regierung sind und den
Wählern ist ja interessant wenn man
jetzt guckt es gibt ja Umfragen wonach
bis zur Hälfte der AF Wähler die sich
selbst nicht als rechte sehen Sarah
Wagenknecht wählen würden Protestwähler
ne sie sagt selber sind Leute die haben
dicken Hals weil sie weil sie einfach
sauer sind über die Politik der
sogenannten etablierten Parteien so ist
das und es sind zwei Parteien die AFD
und SAR wagenknechts künftige Partei
verbindet eine Sache ich habe da nichts
drüber gelesen aber das ist für mich
eigentlich das Auffälligste an beiden
Parteien das sind Germany first Parteien
ja also während für die andere Parteien
die Dinge mindestens genauso wichtig
sind wie Deutschland z.B Europa die
Europäische Union die militärische
Einbindung in den Westen ne das sind ja
ganz ganz wichtige Koordinaten für CDU
SPD FDP und Grüne und diese beiden
Parteien also künftige wagenknechtpartei
und die AFD die für die sind diese
Koordinaten nicht wichtig sondern da
geht es darum sozusagen mehr
Souveränität mehr Autonomie und das ist
ja ein tr raus aus der NATO keine
Waffenlieferungen weder an die Ukraine
noch an Israel ne und solche Dinge genau
ja oder Rückbau der Europäischen Union
austreten und neugründen und so weiter
also möchteag a aus den großen aus den
großen Zusammenhängen in denen die
anderen Parteien sind möchte man
aussteigen und sagen Deutschland soll
seinen eigenen Weg gehen ja wir
verabschieden uns aus dem was man den
Westen nennt ich glaub das haben diese
beiden Parteien gemeinsam und das trifft
bei vielen Leuten einen Nerv und ich
glaube das ist so das entscheidende
Charakteristikum also die die die
etablierten Parteien sozusagen als die
Parteien für die das die zentralen
Koordinaten sind auch historisch
gewachsenen Koordinaten und die neuer
gegründeten Parteien für die sagen das
ist doch alles jetzt nicht relevant oder
wichtig jetzt gucken wir mal auf
Deutschland jetzt gucken mal was ist für
uns gut das scheint mir ein ganz ganz
wichtiger Unterschied zu sein ja genau
es gibt es gibt finde ich also wenn man
sagt wo ist der Vergleich zuur AFD ja
also bei bei einige Themen TRH Sarah
Wagenknecht ganz ähnlich auf ich habe
das in der Sendung häufig erlebt wenn
sie sagt wir haben die dümmste Regierung
aller Zeiten was sehr unterkomplex ist
ne ist einfach so zu sagen so die mit
mit mit so Argumenten wie dumm zu
arbeiten finde ich immer schwierig und
das ist wirklich Blanka Populismus
wei du kritisiere die Politik aber aber
arbeite nicht mit mit solchen Sätzen
oder wenn du dann sagst wir wir haben da
diesen Wirtschaftskrieg vom Zaun
gebrochen wir Deutschland hat ein
Wirtschaftskrieg vom Zaun gebrochen
nicht russland hat einen Krieg gegen die
Ukraine gestartet sondern wir die
dümmste Regierung die Deutschland die
hatte und das hat sie jetzt mehrfach
auch wiederholt
in in Variationen manchmal ist es die
wahrscheinlich dümmste Regierung
manchmal ist es die dümmste Regierung
die schlechteste Regierung die
Deutschland die hatte dieser Sound der
der ist wirklich hart und mich irritiert
auch muss ich zugeben es gibt einen
großen Unterschied zur AFD Sarah
Wagenknecht relativiert die Nazidiktatur
nicht das macht sie
nicht
also ich
mE nichts gemein genau das ist aber
wichtig das mal klar zu sagen natürlich
nicht natürlich nicht nee wir reden auch
nicht damit dass die Parteien sich
ähnlich sind sondern eher dass die
Wählerschaft sich überschneidet das ist
eine kulturkonservative Partei ist auch
was was sie mit der AFD verbindet was
sie sogar mit Teilen der CDU verbindet
es gibt ja auch in der CDU viele Leute
die das mit vegan Ernährung für für
Quatsch halten oder die die gender für
blödsin halten und so tun als wäre das
das große Thema unserer Zeit das ist das
was mich immer so ärgert ja also du
gibst sozusagen ständig Antworten auf
Fragen die keiner gestellt hat und du
bekämpfst Gespenster die außer dir
keiner sieht also im im Alltag der Leute
ganz ehrlich welche Rolle spielt dabei
gender die Leute haben wirklich ganz
andere Sorgen als die Frage wer wie was
wo gendert und das gilt querbeet ja man
kann sagen ist ein Thema wo man einfach
einfach eigentlich nur eine Forderung
stellen kann nämlich mehr Gelassenheit
ja warum sollen die einen nicht ertragen
dass die anderen Gendern ja und warum
sollen die die gender nicht ertragen
dass anderes nicht tut richtig also das
wäre das ist das ist ja tatsächlich die
Lösung in einer liberalen Demokratie
soll doch jeder machen wie er will
richtig ja aber es wird es wird ja
häufig nur deswegen für so wichtig
genommen weil dahinter ist die
Konfliktlinie das einfache Volk das mit
Al dem Mix anfangen kann ne und dann die
da oben das universitäre linksgrüne
milieum die eine Entwicklung
vorantreiben die die normalen Leute
nicht wollen und das ist die
Gemeinsamkeit das bei freien wern so das
war der AFD so das war Saher Wagenknecht
das wird aufgegriffen weil sagen diese
Leute haben keine adäquate Stimme in
diesem Land und das sehen sehr viele
Menschen so und ich bin auch sehr
gespannt wie die anderen Parteien darauf
reagieren werden die müssen in
irgendeiner Form reagieren weil die
Wahlumfragen wenn man überlegt dass die
nächsten Wahlen wo sie antritt ausgen
neben der Europawahl drei Landtagswahlen
im Osten sind genau indem man durchaus
erwarten kann dass beide Parteien sehr
sehr stark sein werden mhm müssen sich
natürlich die Parteien sehr genau
überlegen welche Elemente die den
Wählern bisher bei ihnen fehlen sie
wieder verstärken müssen das erkennt man
ja jetzt schon in der Migrationsfrage ne
die Ampel ist dabei ihre
Migrationspolitik völlig zu verändern
aufgrund des Druckes der aus der AFD
kommt und übrigens auch zu einem
erheblichen Teil aus den Medien die da
auch einfach
radikalere Beschneidung von
migrationsmöglichkeiten und
Asylverfahren und was weiß ich was
fordern also das ist schon
wirkungsmächtig in der
Gesellschaft lass uns gleich mal über
diese Inhalte sprechen aber vielleicht
vorne weg mal kurz ein Satz oder zwei
Sätze über Sarah Wagenknecht Sarah
Wagenknecht fasziniert viele Menschen
sie sie redet anders als andere
Politiker sie positioniert sich
sozusagen gegen gegen das was man
Mainstream nennt sie bleibt bei ihren
Positionen knüppelht da lebt das hufig
sie ist immer sehr sehr auffällig ja
wahnsinnig kontrolliert also ja
ultimativ kontrolliert ich ich habe was
ich vorhin über die Grünen gesagt habe
ja das ist kaum eine Partei also für
mich eigentlich gar keine Partei gibt
die so sehr versucht ihr Bild und ihr
Image dass das Bild der Leute die sie
vertreten in der Öffentlichkeit zu
kontrollieren wie die Grünen das gilt
letztenendes eigentlich auch wenn jand
drüber nachdenke für Sarah Wagenknecht
hat sich immer maximal im Griff und ich
ich habe sogar immer das Gefühl sie sie
hat auch die medienmechanismen so genau
durchschaut je härter sie dann
angegangen wird desto besser für sie und
sie realisiert das auch in der Sekunde
in der es passiert und weiß jetzt muss
ich nichts tun ich muss mich noch nicht
mal wehren ich ma einfach nur weiter und
und und teilweise auch mit mit ganz
absurden Argumenten sozusagen sag mal
sag mal ein Argument was du ganz
besonders absurd findest also was ich
tatsächlich schwierig finde anders ich
will glauben und ich ich glaube es auch
dass Sarah Wagenknecht mal ganz platt
gesagt ein guter Mensch sein möchte und
ein auch ein moralischer Mensch und ich
habe das auch schon oft gesagt ich ich
mag die so privat ich mag sie im Umgang
wir tauscht uns auch ab und zu mal aus
und entgegen sozusagen dem dem Klischee
das da lautet dass wir beide irgendwie
ein ein Problem miteinander hätten muss
ich immer klar entgegentreten und sagen
nein ist nicht so sondern das ist alles
sehr sehr professionell und wir sind an
vielen Punkten ganz ganz
unterschiedliche Auffassung aber an
einigen Punkten eben dann auch nicht der
größte desens Putin doch eigentlich ja
do eigentlich insgesamt genau also raus
aus der NATO beispielsweise und dann
eben sozusagen diese diese eigentlich
urlinke Position zu verlassen zu sagen
pass auf es ist doch eigentlich links
einem Land wie der Ukraine beizustehen
das auf diese Art und Weise überfallen
wird eentlich linke
positionind Seite schwachen ja aber ich
würde ich würde sagen dass nicht nur
Angesicht des ukrainekrieges und das
sage ich ja schon lange wir haben mal
eine Sendung drüber gemacht jeder
Versuch einer linksrechts
Schematisierung von gegenwärtiger
Politik scheitern muss stimmt also in
meiner Kindheit und Jugend war wenn es
um Waffen ging um um Aufrüstung und
Bundeswehr das war ein rechtes Thema und
die Linken waren gegen all das dagegen
heute ist mit den Grünen eine Partei die
sich s irgendwo links verordnen würde
dass die Partei deren Mitglieder und
deren Repräsentanten am stärksten für
Waffenlieferung sind das zeigt also ich
würde ich würde diese Frage niemals zu
einer Frage von rechts oder links machen
weil ich glaube es ist keine Frage von
rechts und links und ich was sind
klassische Fragen von rechts und links
Migrationsfrage ist eigentlich eine
ehemals linke Position zu sagen wir
müssen einen helfen ja und die
Konservativen haben gesagt wir können
nicht allen helfen ja das Boot ist voll
so das war das klassis Schema jetzt
kommt eine linke Politikerin und sagt
sinngemäß wir können nicht alles allen
helfen das Boot ist voll das heißt ich
habe gesehen es gibt jetzt so Grafiken
wo man irgendwie versucht die komplexe
Gemengelage irgendwo noch in ein
rechtslinksschema reinzupressen und die
werden so absurd diese Grafiken dass man
einfach sagen muss ich glaube wir müssen
uns endgültig vom Schema von rechts und
links verabschieden das sind nicht mehr
die Koordinaten im 21 Jahrhundert die
ich glaube die die Frau feindlinien
verlaufen inzwischen ganz wo anders wo
wo verlaufen die am ersten das ich hab
das früher früher habe ich ja mal gesagt
die Konformisten und die Nonkonformisten
also die die Mitte sein wollen ja die
Mitte der Gesellschaft abbilden und
diejenigen die sagen ihr da oben wir
machen da nicht mit ne oder ich habe es
eben gerade gesagt die die Parteien für
die die ganzen Zusammenhänge also NATO
EU Westintegration und so weiter
zentrale Bestandteil ihrer Politik sind
gegen Germany first Parteien die S sagen
das interessiert uns alles nicht wir
müssen an uns denken also das scheint
mir die allerwichtigste Linie heute zu
sein und das rechtslinksschema das kann
man drehen und wenden wie man will damit
kommt man nicht mehr weiter mhm und ich
glaube die wagenknechtpartei ist für
mich sozusagen das Symbol dass das
endgültige Ende des rechtslinksschemas
in der bundesrepublikanischen Topografie
weil diese Partei ist eine Melange aus
diesen beiden Elementen die ist so neu
und so anders die kann man nicht
einordnen mhm wenn man sich mal das das
Programm ein bisschen anschaut ist ja
sehr interessant Peter Tiede von den
Kollegen von BILD hat das mal gemacht
das natürlich sehr sehr zugespitzt aber
sagt es im Grunde ist es so das Gespenst
das Sarah Wagenknecht sozusagen
beschwört ist die freie Marktwirtschaft
ja
Finsternis und Niedergang ist das was
stattdessen ansteht das Land in keiner
guten Verfassung ja und wenn es jemanden
gibt der das Land von der Finsternis
befreien kann dann Sie also Sarah
Wagenknecht macht das Licht an ja mhm
und es stimmt schon ich hatte das
Gespräch vor ein paar Wochen mit ihr
auch und wollte da mal wirklich genauer
verstehen was sie eigentlich meint und
auch da wieder dieses ist wieder dieses
Geraune sozusagen gegen gegen die
Marktwirtschaft ja also die Politik ist
quasi von kon Genen die neolberalen muss
man sagen sie hat ein Buch über über
Ludwig er geschrieben ja und sieht sich
und ist auch jahrelang unterwegs gewesen
mit Vorträgen als Verteidigerin der
sozialen Marktwirtschaft im Sinne Ludwig
erhartz genau und sie wirft den anderen
Parteien vor das verraten zu haben zu
Gunsten einer neoliberalen freien
Marktwirtschaft und das würde
Deutschland zu Grunde richten das ist
ihre
Argumentation ja und es gipfelte dann
ich habe dann gesagt was passiert denn
dann mit den mit den großen
Lebensmittelkonzernen und ich habe dann
ganz konkret als Beispiel gefragt nach
Edeka und die Antwort war das wird
natürlich zerschlagen das sagte sie
nicht direkt sie hat ein anderes Wort
benutzt ja sie sagte ja da müssen wir
dann müssen wir entflechten das war das
schöne Wort ja entflech he entflechten
das ist so kartellpolitischer Begriff
entflechten also Edeka zerschlagen das
war das Thema sie redet dannch so und
redet von übergriffigen
digitalmonopolisten und ja das sind die
großen großen teonzerne gem ja gut das
sehen wir in gewissen Hinsicht auch so
ne dass keine Datensicherheit mehr haben
das ist keine Kontrolle der gfas also
der ganz großen digitalkonzerne redet ja
nicht von deutschen Unternehmen redet ja
von den ne sie redet von von Google von
Meta von wie sie wie sie da alle sind
ganz genau genau aber wenn man das so
hört dann denkt man okay also uns gibt's
in dieser Welt gar nicht mehr aber es
gibt natürlich SAP und Siemens und die
Telekom und die Allianz und VW und BMW
und so weiter und das Rezept ist immer
das muss der Staat jetzt machen ja diese
marktbeherrschenden bösen Konzern der
Staat kann nicht länger zugucken bei
diesen Entwicklung genau na jetzt kommt
V all folgendes in in einem in das das
meiste Wirtschaftsrecht ist ja auch
europäisch festgelegt ja also die dieses
Bekenntnis zur freien sozialen
Marktwirtschaft ist ja nicht nicht nur
in Deutschland so das ist ja auch
Grundkonstitution der Europäischen Union
viele entscheidende Dinge im Bereich des
Wettbewerbsrechts und so weiter sind ja
europäisch geregelt das heißt wenn du da
jetzt sagst wir machen das von nun an
anders dann geht das wahrscheinlich
tatsächlich nur indem du aus der
Europäischen Union rausgehst wenn du
aber aus der EU rausgehst natürlich
irgendwie verbunden immer mit so
Gedanken D machen wir das irgendwie
anders und neu das kriegst du
wahrscheinlich nicht wieder hin also
wenn ein Land wie Deutschland da
rausgeht dann weiß ich nicht was die
Europäische Union noch sein soll wenn
dann Frankreich vielleicht unter Marine
lepen auch noch rausgeht gibt's keine
Europäische Union mehr und ich glaube
auch nicht dass auf absehbare Zeit
irgendetwas anderes an diese Stelle
treten wird also ich glaube da entsteht
Chaos und Vakuum richtig was auch
natürlich ein ganz wichtiger Punkt ist
ist wenn äh die wagenknechtpartei
tatsächlich im Bund stark werden sollte
was wir jetzt noch nicht wissen was
einige sagen Potenzial 20 27% das kann
ja sowieso im Augenblick überhaupt gar
keiner abschätzen und die AFD
bekanntermaßen wohl auch über 20% kriegt
jedenfalls wenn morgen Wahl wäre dann
führt das irgendwann in eine Situation
wo die anderen Parteien also die jetzt
regierenden Parteien mit der Ampel dann
vielleicht irgendwie mit der CDU
regieren dass also nicht nur drei
Parteien Koalition haben sondern wir
haben bei den etablierten Parteien
vielleicht irgendwann sogar eine vier
Parteien Koalition um noch eine Mehrheit
zu haben und das hat folgenden fatalen
Effekt wir sehen das ja schon be der
Ampel eine drei Parteien Koalition
funktioniert ja schon fast gar nicht es
ist schon unglaublich schwierig wichtige
Entscheidung zu treffen somal wir ja vor
gewaltigen Umbauarbeiten stehen ne
Rentensystem Krankensystem und so weiter
die immer weiter vertagt werden die
nicht richtig angegangen werden wenn wir
jetzt noch eine vier Parteien Koalition
haben da ist ja der Streit programmiert
dann haben wir ein Mediensystem in dem
jeder Streit natürlich auch riesengroß
aufgebauscht wird ne ich meine Politiker
haben sich auch früher untereinander
gestritten aber es wurde nicht so ein
boheid da drum gemacht jedenfalls nicht
in diesem Ausmaß wie heute wo jedes
falsche Komma irgendwie entsprechend
bewertet wird und als Beispiel von
Misstrauen oder der kann den nicht
leiden und so weiter aufgebaut wird das
heißt es immer schwieriger zu regieren
und dann tatsächlich irgendwann
vielleicht eine vierparteien Koalition
und je schwieriger die Zusammenarbeit
der etablierten Parteien dann wird weil
sie so viele sind und weil man sich in
vielen Punkten nicht einigen kann umso
mehr profitieren dann die beiden Germany
first Parteien davon das ist die
Entwicklung die man so am Horizont sieht
muss man in gewisser Weise da auch nicht
jemandem bisarer Wagenknecht Respekt
zollen dass sie bei dem Thema und da
kommt jetzt sozusagen die Verbindung
auch zu den Medien bei dem bei dem Mega
Thema Migration hat sie sich als eine
der ersten wirklich aus der Deckung
getraut und hat gesagt wir können das so
nicht weitermachen ist dafür wahnsinnig
verprügelt worden das als Linke
Politikerin ja die fordert wir müssen
die die Grenzen zumachen wir können wir
müssen Migration in ir aus Bereich der
etablierten Parteien als rechte
beschimpft worden jene etierten parte
die genau das jetzt machen genau richtig
genau und die die Art und Weise wie sie
da ihr Argument immer durchgezogen hat
und es auch gut begründet hat und auch
gesagt hat pass auf das ihr könnt das
alle so sehen ihr könnt auch mit
Ideologie kommen und so weiter aber ich
sage euch ich habe mein Ohr an den
kleinen Leuten und ich kriege mit welche
riesigen Verwerfungen das irgendwann
auslösen wird da muss man sagen war sie
eine der ersten die da sehr früh nach
vorne gegangen ist äh und jetzt in
gewisser Weise mit mit diesen
umfrageerfolgen sind sie ja in erster
Linie im Moment nur aber dennoch belohnt
wird äh und ich glaube schon dass diese
Partei die da kommen wird das Potenzial
hat diese deutsche Landschaft politische
Landschaft nachhaltig zu verändern ja
also ich habe das ja auch gesagt ich
glaube das ist das Ende des
rechtslinksschemas wie wir es kannten
das ist eine der wichtigsten Veränderung
das zweite wird dann sein ich meine
stell dir mal den Horror vor eine Partei
zu gründen was passiert wenn man eine
Partei gründet du hast auf einmal
100.000 Leute die möchten auch in die
Partei rein die möchten auch Ämter vor
alleningen wenn die Partei gute Chancen
hat auch tatsächlich im Parlamenten
vertreten zu sein und die allerersten
die in so einer Situation zu dir stoßen
sind
Spinner
welterlösungspropheten jeglicher kouleur
ja Leute mit mit totalerklärungen für
alles oder mit einfachen Lösungen für
ultraakomplexe Probleme die strömen da
hin so und die kannst du ja auch nicht
kannst ja nicht als erstes ein
Intelligenztest oder eine
Gesinnungsprüfung oder so machen wenn
jemand in deine Partei kommt und die
erzählen dann unter Umständen noch in
irgendwelche Kameras irgendeinen
Blödsinn und belasten die Partei damit
das zweite ist du brauchst sehr gutes
fähiges Personal ja und zwar sehr viele
davon du musst ja Landesverbände
aufbauen Kommunalverbände und soast 16
Landesverbände du mus überall Rute Leute
kriegen also e nicht die Spinner ja die
die charen zulaufen sondern Leute aus
anderen Parteien und das ist das was bei
macron so gut funktioniert hat ne also
bei macron haben sehr viele intelligente
fähige Leute das sinkende Schiff ihrer
Parteien verlassen und sind zu ihm
gegangen ohne das wäre das ja gar nicht
möglich gewesen eine Partei in diesem
Eiltempo eine auch eine personenpartei
in diesem Eiltempo überhaupt aufzubauen
und das wird die wirklich spannende
Frage sein wie viele Leute aus anderen
Parteien die müssen ja nicht nur aus der
Linkspartei kommen werden dann
dazustoßen und wie viel unfähige Leute
werden dazu stoßen und werden
ob sie es wollen oder nicht damit die
Partei schon in Ansätzen diskreditieren
also eine Parteigründung ist ein
unglaublich dickes Brett m und es kann
funktionieren siee macron siee Sebastian
Kurz auch in Österreich aber es ist
natürlich auch gefährlich neusagen alles
auf eine Person zuzuschneiden äh die
Frage was passiert wenn er oder sie an
der Spitze plötzlich ausfällt alles an
dieser kommenden Partei ist
ausschließlich auf Sie zugeschnitten und
ob sie das auf Strecke durchhält diesen
diesen brutalen Druck weiß ich nicht sie
ist aber jemand der medial natürlich
unglaublich gut funktioniert
und das ist sozusagen das große Plus
aber weil du gerade sagtest macron ich
meine auch in in Frankreich siehst du es
macron macht ja auch Frankreich first
Politik wenn du so willst ja also was
der an Industriepolitik macht wie der
Startups gründet wie der anfängt große
Konzerne mit Steuererleichterungen und
so weiter systematisch ins Land zu holen
also das ist der wie außenpolitisch wie
außenpolitisch deutlich gemacht hat dass
Europa einen dritten Pol bilden sollte
also sie stärker von der US-Politik
entfernen und eigenständiger werden am
Beispiel als sie gesagt als er gesagt
hat für Taiwan sind wir nicht
verantwortlich und so also da da ist es
auch ganz stark ich habe bislang immer
gedacht dass diese first Politik ne dass
die in Zeiten der Europäischen Union
eigentlich der Vergangenheit angehören
sollte dann haben wir ja gesehen es gibt
ja viele europäische Länder die das
immer beibehalten haben Ungarn da gilt
absolut Ungarn first und Europa kommt
irgendwo ganz ganz zum Schluss wir haben
es auch in Polen unter der peacepartei
haben wir das haben wir das auch erlebt
und es war auch auch immer so selbst für
für Deutschland der ein starker Motor
der Europäischen Union war du hast
im Grunde genommen deine deine Erfolge
die hast du nationalisiert und deine
Misserfolge hast auf Europa geschoben
das hat also Gerhard Schröder so gemacht
und das hat Kohl hat's nicht gemacht
weil er die Europäische Union ist ja
zentraler Architekt des ganzen gewesen
aber es ist so typisch für sehr sehr
viele Politiker immer gewesen auf die
Europäische Union auch zu schimpfen ne
und das führt dann dazu dass dieses
Bedürfnis der Leute eigentlich wie wir
es in England dann am Ende mit dem
brexit hatten ne die Europäische Union
die saugt uns einfach nur aus und wir
finanzieren die anderen und dann auch
noch Länder die wirtschaftlich überhaupt
keine eigene Kraft haben und das kann ja
sowieso alles nicht gehen und so diese
diese ganzen Tendenzen arbeiten ja schon
seit langer Zeit gegen Europa und ich
habe immer diese first Politik für
Politik von gestern gehalten ne ich habe
immer gedacht nee so der Weltenlauf der
entwickelt sich so der der Nationalismus
der geht jetzt mal ein ganzes Stück
zurück so wie Francis Fukuyama damals
gesagt ne liberale Demokratien setzen
sich durch und damit natürlich verbunden
auch globale Zusammenarbeit nmen zu
Nationalismus hat weniger Raum und
inzwischen weiß ich nicht mehr ob das
was ich für Gespenster von gestern halte
nicht die Geister von morgen sind also
ich glaube wir erleben da gerade große
Umbruchszeiten ja das ist wahr ich meine
weil du gerade Ungarn sagst das
Interessante ist ja wie es diese Leute
machen ne also jemand wie Viktor Orban
z.B der war als er an die Macht kam
2010 war er Anführer einer Partei die
glaube ich der heutigen CDU gar nicht so
unähnlich war ja bürgerlich konservativ
ja
und über die Rechtsradikalen ja von
anderen Parteien hat seine Partei die
Nase gerümpft heute viele Jahre später
genau da angekommen ja so genau ja aber
was ich interessant finde ist und das
sagen auch Politikwissenschaftler die
sich damit auskennen auf einer wie soll
man sagen technischen Ebene sind die
Orban Leute aber auch die katinskis ich
meine es waren waren zwei zwei
Professoren die einfach sich das
ja Rechtsprofessoren die sich das System
angeguckt haben ganz unspektakulär und
die Orb Leute genauso die sind geschickt
darin das System auszuspielen schlaue
Juristen aber keine große extreme
Ideologie die reden auch nicht radikal
die kommen nicht wirklich radikal daher
zumindest nicht in dem Moment indem sie
sozusagen nach der Macht greifen aber
sie machen es so in kleinen Schritten
und irgendjemand ich ich weiß nicht mehr
wer es war der
sagte mal da muss man nicht mit
Extremismus Theorien kommen ja sondern
das sind das das sind auch keine
totalitären Ideologen das sind
konservative im Machtrausch so hat er
sich damals ausgedrückt man muss sich
diese dieses diese Wirkmechanismen
einfach mal klar machen und das finde
ich ein sehr sehr guten Punkt pun das
das ist genauso man muss man muss kein
kein weil weil Leute wollen dieses
extreme nicht aber es anders zu machen
Smart zu machen zu sagen okay dann gehen
wir ein bisschen an die Verfassung ran
dann setzen wir die Altersgrenze für
Richter einfach erstmal runter dann
schicken wir die alten Richter alle in
die Rente und so weiter und dann
besetzen wir das mit unseren Leuten und
so übernimmst du Schritt für Schritt
übernimmst du das ganze Ding das geht in
kleinen leisen Schritten vor sich hin
und das ist das was mir immer Angst
macht und wenn ich mir jetzt noch
vorstelle dass wir vielleicht auch noch
Regierungswechsel in Frankreich oder
sowas kriegen und ähm das dann ein ein
noch stärkeres Frankreich first da ist
und ein noch stärkeres Deutschland first
und so weiter und Europa ja dadurch
zusammengehalten wurde dass Deutschland
und Frankreich äh den die Lock gezogen
haben und Kohl persönlich den ganzen
Bahnhof und schon unter Merkel sichtbar
war wenn man nicht mehr den ganzen
Bahnhof zieht dann entwickelt sich das
eher wieder zurück mhm könnte ich mir
könnte ich mir vorstellen dass gewaltige
Veränderungen auf Europa zukommen und
das ist so eine Aussicht über die wir
vielleicht auch im Augenblick viel zu
wenig denken weil eben diese diese
firstend Tendenzen fast in allen
europäischen Ländern sich massiv
verstärken dann kommt dann etwas
wirklich ganz anderes das ist dann das
Ende von Europa wie wir es kannten
abschließend gesagt Richard das das
Programm und da und da ist tatsächlich
auch die Parallele zur AFD äh und auch
zu vielen anderen
Rechten und und rechtspopulistischen
Strömungen und Parteien in ganz Europa
und ehrlich gesagt auch auf der ganzen
Welt dass das eigentlich beunruhende
daran ist du brauchst gar kein
wirkliches Programm und wenn du jemanden
von der AFD aber auch Sarah wagenkneft
wenn du sie wirklich ganz hart mal drauf
abkloopst was ist denn eigentlich jetzt
eure Lösung was ist euer Rezept dann
merkst Du da ist nichts da ist nur ganz
viel warme Luft aber keine wirklichen
Rezepte weil NAT relativier muss man
dazu sagen welche Partei Markus jetzt
mal Hand aufs Herz hat Rezepte
kennst du eine im bundestagvertreten die
grandiose Rezepte für die Lösung unserer
Rentenfrage ja für die Neuerfindung
unseres Gesundheitssystems hat siehst du
da irgendwas kennst du jemand der ein
Masterplan zum Thema Migration vorlegen
kann es ist doch das große Versäumnis
aller Parteien inzwischen und das gilt
nicht nur für die First Parteien sondern
es gilt auch für die etablierten
Parteien dass keine langfristigen
strategischen Überlegungen mehr da sind
wo man lich hin will sondern das auch in
einer in einer Welt wo die Medien diese
enorme Dominanz haben und die
aufregungsnetzwerke der sozialen Medien
in das einfach überhaupt gar keine
langfristige Politik mehr stattfindet
dass sich das alles hin und her dreht
mal nach da dann mal da oh dann ist
jetzt das passiert da müssen wir nur
noch reagierende Politik ich will nicht
sagen dass das früher ganz anders war
wir überschätzen auch gerne die
Politiker von gestern was für
langfristige Strategen sie waren aber es
gab doch einige zentral langfristige
Agenden ja also die Errichtung der
sozialen Marktwirtschaft und die
Westintegration in der Adenauer und
ehzeit die aussönung mit dem Osten
einschließlich der Erschließung der
Absatzmärkte im Osten und auch das Gas
was damals schon Thema war will die
Brandzeit und nach innen mehr
demokratiew wagen Liberalisierung der
Gesellschaft unter Helmut Kohl sozusagen
Wiederherstellung der wirtschaftlichen
Stärke nach der großen Krise Ende der
70er Jahre die sogenannte geistig
moralische wende das waren ja und dann
vor allen gegen dies massive
Vorantreiben der Europäischen Union das
waren ja gigantische strategische Ziele
bei Schröder war es in eine andere
Position zu Amerika zu kommen
außenpolitisch stärkere Europa
deutsch-französische Achse stärker
machen mehr europäisch souveräne Politik
und nach innen die har4 Reform also da
gab's Agenden und mit Merkel fängt eine
Politik an die keine Agenda mehr
hat und alles was im Wahlkampf dann am
Ende erzählt wird schlät legt sich Stgt
ja nicht zu Buche also es ist ja nicht
so als ob die Grünen jetzt die große
nachhaltigkeitsrevolution gemacht hätten
die im Wahlkampf gesagt haben wir haben
noch vier Jahre und dann es geht alles
den Bach unter dafür ist in den vier
Jahren wenig passiert ging auch
ausgesprochen wenig räum ich auch gerne
ein auch nicht mit einem
Koalitionspartner FDP aber ich sehe im
Augenblick gar nicht was sind denn
wirklich die strategischen Ziele auf die
wir hinaus wollen und wie gehen wir denn
die ganz großen Probleme diesem Land an
und wenn man das Gefühl hat die Parteien
haben doch alle keine Lösung und keine
Rezepte davon profitieren die First
Parteien ja die am lautesten anprangern
dass die etablierten Parteien keine
Lösung haben ja aber es gibt den noch
einen einen großen Unterschied auch weil
du gerade die die Grünen nennst aber
auch die CDU auch die SPD auch die FDP
wenn man mit mit Leuten dieser Parteien
spricht dann habe ich immer das Gefühl
okay vielleicht hat er nicht die
perfekte Lösung vielleicht weiß sie
nicht ganz genau worauf es am Ende
hinauslaufen soll okay aber es gibt
zumindest erkennbar das bemüh darum das
Ringen um eine Lösung um eine gute Idee
wenn du mit AFD Leuten sprichst da
merkst du ganz schnell und da wird auch
kein großer he raus gemacht das einzige
Programm das wir haben ist wir sind
dagegen gegen absolut alles und dagegen
zu sein ja das ist kein Programm ja da
muss man mal Alexander Gauler noch mal
zitieren ja rontim ist kein Programm hat
er mal gesagt die Wahrheit die bittere
Wahrheit ist rontim ist mittlerweile ein
Programm und und ehrlich gesag übg noch
nicht es gibt noch kein parte ja ich hab
ich habe aber das Gespräch mit ihr
geführt lohnt sich da noch mal
reinzugucken bei ihrem letzten Besuch
weil ich wirklich mal wissen wollte was
ist denn ihr Rezept und ehrlich gesagt
kam auch da ganz viel einfach dagegen
bin dagegen dagegen dagegen dagegen wenn
es ein Parteiprogramm gibt dann werden
wir folgendes machen wir haben ja schon
das der AFD mal gründlich untersucht
dann werden wir das der
wagenknechtpartei untersuchen und dann
gucken wir uns auch noch mal die
Programme der etablierten Parteien an
und dann machen wir zu jedem eine
Sendung und gucken genau was wir davon
halten du willst du willst du willst
wieder recht haben okay ich will nur
einfach darauf hinaus in heutigen Zeiten
ja ist das mit großen Lösungen ja
eigentlich Utopie ja es gibt keine
großen Lösungen für die großen
gesellschaftlichen Probleme vor denen
wir stehen es gibt keine einfachen
Antworten es gibt keine großen Lösungen
das ist alles das was die Leute gerne
haben wollen und das ist alles das was
nicht
existiert aber ich bin ja schon froh
wenn ich jemanden treffe oder wenn ich
setze im Parteiprogramm find wo ich
denke das könnte ein spannender neuer
realistischer Weg seinm so ob den jemand
geht ob dir jemand einfällt ob den
jemand macht das weiß ich nicht aber das
wäre so meine Erwartung an ein gutes
Parteiprogramm dein Wort in Gottes
Gehörgang Richard ich danke Dir sehr
gute Zeit doch in Südtirol ja danke
schön genießt das schöne Essen und die
sehr netten Menschen ist ja mit
Sicherheit aufgefallen abolut großartig
der Südtirol an sich neigt zu
Freundlichkeit und
insofern zur Freundlichkeit und zur
Gastfreundlichkeit auf jeden Fall leider
sind die Berge völlig
verhangen ich bin jetzt das fünfte Mal
in südtyol und hier hat die Sonne
geschienen und ich glaube das ist nicht
repräsentativ ich mit Messner mal auf
dem Ortler gestanden zwischen Jax und es
war einfach nur trüb ja das passiert das
passiert im Herbst fü mich dann wie im
Himalaya im Spätherbst oder so du wir
haben aber 300 Sonnentage im Jahr darauf
sind wir wahnsinnig stolz und Südtirol
ist das Land wem ich immer sage ist egal
wie sehr es regnet egal wie mies es ist
aber irgendwann im Laufe dieses elenden
Tages kommt dann die Sonne zum Vorschein
und das ist fast immer so darauf kannst
du dich eigentlich verlassen dann
verlasse ich mich jetzt da drauf und
warte mal die nächsten Stunden ab
Richard ich danke Dir sehr ja ich danke
dir B alles lie tschü
tschüss eine Produktion von mhoch2 und
podstars bei OMR im Auftrag des
[Musik]
ZDF